well we're not going to make it as uh to
gain that parliamentary bridgehead
adam we've just had a couple of good
results and aberdeenshire
here where we're over three percent but
you need four four and a half percent to
get that uh less seat
so i don't think we're going to make it
this time around but
for all that you know we now as a party
having celebrated our sixth anniversary
that is to say we are six weeks old
yesterday
uh we've got 5000 members and we'll have
the best part of 50
000 votes across scotland we've got two
members of parliament and 20 councillors
so we're looking forward to the future
as a political party
and i think that future is going to be a
very very good one indeed
well the members of parliament of course
are defectors uh
from the snp uh as you say you've
uh may be lucky you've got three percent
of the vote that doesn't seem to be
uh frankly a basis uh for continuing to
carry on
well it is adam and if i could just
correct you one of her members apartment
wasn't elected as an snp he was
elected as an independent uh a a
nationalist uh
not as an snp politician but nonetheless
they are two members of parliament
you know when i led the snp for the
first time back in 1990 adam we had
three members of parliament so uh
you know from from small acorns
mighty oaks spring adam and alapa
are going to have the great advantage
that the argument we've been putting
forward in this election
is going to be proven to be correct and
that is to say there's going to be about
a million
snp votes on the list the regional lists
which are going to be wasted not just
that
they're going to let in tory and labour
politicians by the back door
and while the snp have wasting votes in
the list
the unionists labor and touring liberal
democrats have been voting tactically in
the constituencies to stop the snp
winning key constituencies now i make no
complaint about that
that is uh smart voting by the labor and
tory supporters
but i mean the same contrast
i was going to make the contrast between
that smart voting and the snp
leadership sending the troops over the
top and wasting a million votes
but as you know nicola sturgeon
describes that as gambling and gaming
the system
and uh it appears on this occasion
how can it be gaming the system for the
independent supporters
if the unionist supporters are voting
tactically at constituency level and
then barton and eastwood
snp will stop from winning
constituencies by
gaming the system by the unionist
supporters now look
i made no complaint about tactical
voting in first pass to post but if
we're making no complaint about that
don't complain about an argument which
says
list vote shouldn't be allowed to go to
waste and independence supporters should
vote
for independence supporting candidates
i'm really saying
that aleppo's argument is going to be
proved correct and sometimes in politics
when you win an argument you don't get
the electoral reward first time round
but you certainly get it next time
mr simon you're going down fighting but
really as a political force
you personally are finished aren't you
well
i'm more concerned about aleppo and
aleppo as a party of our 5000 members
are planning our annual
conference in june and uh meeting with
some of our candidates this morning and
it'll be up to the conference of course
but we were planning to stand in the
local elections next year
so alapa will likely be contesting the
next set of elections in scotland
look in six weeks adam five thousand
members two members of parliament
what about you are you gonna stay on as
leader are you gonna carry on as a
candidate
well who leads alipa will depend on the
party conference
i'm the interim leader through this
election i was invited to do that and i
accepted that charge
but uh who leads aleppo not just who
leads it but who's on the executive
all the positions will be filled by the
annual conference what i'm certain of
this
thank you very much indeed for joining
us lots more coming up on the elections
here on sky news